what is up everybody it's annamac here
for
anime opera and today i will be breaking
down the latest events
in attack on titan events that really
crossed
a critical line in the development of
aaron
as a character what just happened will
have a massive impact on the entire
story
going forward this was a brutal chapter
and yet something else might be going on
here
something that could change everything
so let's
get into it if you enjoy the attack on
titan content on this channel and you
want us to keep it going please leave a
like to let me know
and if you're new to anime out pro or
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications i know it can be a
hassle especially if you're watching the
video without signing in
but if you don't actually subscribe and
then hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
you're never gonna see a lot of our
videos it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain
attack on titan manga spoilers we're
dealing with the very latest events in
the story so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the latest chapter
starts off with that
pickpocket boy who lives in a refugee
camp on the continent
the same boy who was saved by the scouts
during their initial incognito visit to
marley as you'll recall this kid whose
name is ramsey attempted to steal from
the scouts
but he was caught and nearly killed by
the marlenes after levi revealed that he
was a pickpocket
he was saved by the scouts after sasha
claimed that he was her little brother
and that no crime had actually taken
place ramsay was later
also saved by aaron from being beaten to
death in the present time
ramsay is shown hiding his stolen loot
he speaks to another little boy halil
who appears to be his brother ramsay
tells halil that once they steal enough
valuables
they will be able to find a better place
for the refugees to live
it turns out that since his encounter
with the scouts and aaron
ramsey had had one of his hands cut off
for stealing and halil warns him that if
he keeps stealing he is going to lose
his
other hand as well but ramsay is
determined
to keep going the refugees can't
continue living
in the raggedy tents that they are
currently living in every winter people
die
just because of their poor living
conditions and ramsay can't sit back and
watch as this continues to happen
ramsay is of course aware of the risk
that he is taking
and in fact he shows halil where his
loot is hidden so that if ramsay is
caught and killed at some point in the
future
halil will still be able to find the
valuables and give them to the others
this brief conversation between the two
refugee boys is absolutely brilliant
from a narrative perspective and i say
that because in just
two short pages this exchange tells us
so much about the struggle of the
refugees
and about the motivations of ramsay as a
character these pages also reveal the
extent of ramsay's commitment and his
willingness to sacrifice his body
and even his own life for his people
even at such a young
age and i honestly think that these two
pages the first two pages of this
chapter are a perfect example of
brilliant
manga storytelling so much is revealed
in such a short period of time
and we suddenly understand and actually
care deeply about the struggles of these
poor refugee children
kudos to isama and the attack on titan
team this is a great example of why
attack on titan is such a great manga
the conversation between the two refugee
boys is suddenly disrupted
as they see that people from the town
are running for their lives
on top of that the ground itself is
shaking
the birds and other animals are
panicking and fleeing
in all directions as the boys look out
over the hilltop
they realize that millions of giant
titans are
coming their way and these titans are
leveling
everything in sight we then jump to a
flashback that shows
aaron's perspective back when the scouts
had secretly visited the continent
aaron already knew that he would one day
massacre
all of these innocent people we know he
had access to the attack titan's future
memories
even then and so even though he wasn't
sure when
exactly this was going to happen aaron
already knew that he would one day
return to this place
and that he would destroy everyone and
everything in it
including ramsey in the flashback aaron
is clearly conflicted about what he
knows that he is one day going to do
on the one hand he realizes that finding
a peaceful solution
is going to be impossible and that he is
going to have to go through with the
rumbling in order to save parodies from
the outside world
but on the other hand aaron wonders what
his own mother would think of him if she
knew that after
everything that happened to them during
the fall of shiganchina
aaron would one day be doing the same
thing and
even worse to millions of innocent
people
aaron thinks back to grisha's showdown
with frida reese and the other members
of the rhys family aaron knows that if
king fritz's ideology was followed
to its inevitable conclusion then all
aldians would eventually be exterminated
and even though that would have been a
tragedy compared to the population of
the rest of the world
the extermination of the eldian
population would actually have meant a
lot less
death and destruction than aaron's
current plan
at least in terms of sheer scale and
numbers
and yet aaron simply could not agree
with
carl fritz's ideology he could not stand
by and allow
everyone he ever knew and loved his
entire nation
to be mercilessly sacrificed just
because their ancestors made mistakes
hundreds of years ago aaron realizes
that he is now
the same as reiner no actually he is
even worse
because while reiner wanted to sacrifice
the aldians on the island for what he
believed to be the greater good
aaron is prepared to sacrifice the rest
of the world for the benefit of parodies
and its people i recently made an entire
20 minute video about the tragic life of
aaron
and in that video i talked about aaron's
stunning and tragic progression
from an idealistic boy who wanted to
save humanity from the titans
to a cold and calculating mass murderer
who decided to destroy humanity
with the help of the titans i won't go
into too many details about aaron's
internal struggle here so as not to
repeat myself too much
but if that is something you are
interested in feel free to check out
that video
link in the description back in the
present
all the refugees including ramsey and
halil are trying to get away from the
rumbling
but it's no use the titans are too fast
and they have already cut off most of
the possible escape routes
no one is safe and escape is impossible
young and old alike all the people here
are doomed to fall victim to
aaron and the rumbling as we see ramsay
and halil
trying to escape the inevitable aaron
reveals that the outside world
didn't end up being anything like what
he thought that it would be
it was very different from the world
that he had seen
in armin's books in fact aaron was
disappointed when he learned that
humanity lived
outside the walls aaron would have liked
it better if the outside world was
nothing but
vast and endless wilderness just the
peace
and harmony of nature and this is a very
important point and it echoes something
that i mentioned
in my tragic life of aaron video even at
the very beginning when we thought that
the main villains of the story were
these gigantic
inhuman monsters known as the titans
there were always
clues that the real villains were
actually humans
including the corrupt and oppressive
government on the island the kidnappers
who killed mikasa's parents
and so on as the story goes on it is
only confirmed further
that the real villains of the story are
not some mythical
inhuman monsters but rather humans
themselves
when we take this into consideration it
is no wonder that aaron was disappointed
to learn that humans lived in the
outside world
if the outside world had been empty of
human life like the eldians behind the
walls
thought it was then this outside world
would be full of
endless possibilities there would have
been vast lands to explore
and aaron would have been free to go
anywhere and see
anything but wherever there are human
beings
there are also wars suffering greed and
so many other
negative things as we see aaron in his
flashback
telling ramsay that he is sorry in the
present
both ramsay and halil are crushed to
death by a colossal
titan and just as these two refugee boys
meet their tragic end we see the
original
emir fritz standing on the street and
watching the entire scene unfold
but here's the interesting thing from
the way that emir is portrayed here
to me it looks like she is watching this
scene from the future
she kind of looks like aaron and zeke
looked when they were watching grisha's
memories
from the future maybe i'm looking too
much into this
but i feel like this brief glimpse of
emir could end up being
very important let's not forget that
while aaron and zeke were looking in on
scenes of grisha from the past
aaron was able to influence the past by
interfering with it directly
future aaron was able to convince grisha
to take the founding titan power
after he was about to give up on his
plan if this is actually a emir from the
future
or perhaps emir from the past witnessing
a future memory through the attack
titan could she actually do something to
change
what just happened could she somehow hit
the rewind button
and influence aaron in a way that
prevents this tragedy from happening i
might be overthinking this
but that brief glimpse of amir fritz
could end up being more important than
we realize
we then see a series of scenes between
armin and aaron which are a blend of
flashbacks
and events happening in the present on
the one hand a young aaron dreams about
freedom and soaring above the clouds as
free as a bird
but on the other hand those clouds
beneath aaron are not
clouds at all they are the scorching
steam
coming off the wall titans the steam
of the rumbling and speaking of armin
the chapter then jumps to armin
in the present armin appears to have
felt through the paths
that aaron was thinking about him but
instead of aaron
annie calls out to armin and he sits
next to her and has an emotional
conversation with annie
annie thanks aaron for talking to her
for all those years that she spent
trapped in the crystal annie says that
she thought that she would go
crazy from the loneliness and having
armin and hitch to talk to was the only
thing that she had to look forward to
for
all those years and he doesn't
understand why
armin would waste his time talking to a
crystal rock
but armin blushes and says that he
wanted to see her
strongly implying that armin does indeed
like her
and at the thought of this annie blushes
too
so the armin and annie shippers will
definitely appreciate
this section of the chapter there is
definitely something there
although with attack on titan romance
seems to always be
just an afterthought armin then confides
in annie that he always thought that the
promise he had made to aaron as a child
would
one day come true and that is of course
the promise to go on a journey
into the vast unknown world beyond the
walls
and he tells armin that the unknown
world wasn't that great after all
and armin admits that the world is very
different from what he and aaron had
dreamed of
but as a seagull lands on the railing of
the ship right next to armin
and as he looks the seagull right in the
eye armin says that he still wants to
believe
that the unknown must be out there
somewhere
beyond those walls in my opinion
the word unknown here represents the
ultimate outcome
of the rumbling and the still uncertain
future
of the world but after what we've just
seen aaron do
is the fate of the world already set in
stone or can things
actually change the first part of this
chapter definitely suggests that the
line has been crossed and that there is
no going back for aaron
or for the world itself however then we
see
emir fritz potentially looking at the
present from the future or the past
and then the second part of the chapter
shows us that armin still has
faith that something could change armin
still believes that this current tragic
outcome
may not be set in stone at least that is
my interpretation
of this armin moment and of his
conversation with annie
but let me know what you guys think can
the tragic present
potentially be changed perhaps by emir
fritz
influencing the present from the future
or maybe emir from the past
changing the future after seeing the
future memories through the attack
titan or could armin potentially do
something to influence aaron and make
him change his mind
or has aaron crossed the point of no
return
is aaron already destined to destroy the
entire world
or will something or someone change his
mind
please share your thoughts comments and
predictions
down below if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more attack on titan
content on the channel please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime pro
or you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar i want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make
videos like this one possible an extra
special thank you to
alpha a disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget are the one tier
patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including ingrata alolan adam the world
steelers acquired respect pate heffer
jonathan king brandon aviles papa smurf
emperor otaku
thomas jones and kin mano finally
big thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson king
zeldris
anatoly kazatsky angel cruz cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia octor
jessica kayla fong
hinokami and water bonnie parks rathuen
de ora deadly saint
and stern hawkins if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you